So here we go.
From uncle Jake
when I was a kid there was a game that
we made up that we played during recess
if it was raining outside.
So recess was in the gym?
Yeah,
the game was kind of like dodge ball
except you could change sides at any time.
And we called the game bash ball
and it was a pretty fun game.
So the way you'd play basketball is first
we would pick teams and then we would
put a bunch of balls on the half
court line down the middle of the gym.
And then the two teams would go to the
walls on opposite sides of the gym with
the balls right there in the middle.
And then when everyone was on
the walls and we were all set,
someone would yell go,
okay.
And as soon as that yellow came,
we would run to the center as fast
as we could and try and grab a ball.
And once you had a ball in your hand,
the goal was kind of like dodge ball.
The goal was to throw the ball at someone
on the other side and just like dodge
ball, if you hit them and they
didn't catch it, they were out
and if they caught the ball that
you threw at them, you were out.
And so that part was very
much like dodge ball.
But this is what made the game a little
bit different when it made sense,
when you fought it made sense you could
actually just switch to the other side
and play for the other team.
And what that meant is that eventually
there would only be two people left,
one on one side and one side,
one on the other side.
And when one of them hit
the other one with the ball,
the last person in the game would be the
champion. So it was a pretty good game.
It was pretty fun.
But I could never actually win the game.
I would do okay. I was pretty good
at it, but I wouldn't ever win.
Yeah,
that bothered me a little bit.
I wanted to win and there was
another kid named Billy in the class.
Yeah.
And he would play the game with us and
he was a smaller kid sometimes we called
them little belly. He was very
nice. He was tough. He was small,
but he was tough and he was determined.
He was also very quiet.
He didn't say much. He played, he played
the game hard, but he didn't talk much.
Yeah.
And he was probably about
the same as me at basketball.
He was about as good as I was
and that meant that he never,
he actually won the game either,
but I could tell that like me,
he wanted to win the game for sure.
Okay.
Then one day it was raining outside,
so we had recess in the gym that we were
kind of excited because that meant we
got to play basketball.
Yeah.
And it just so happened that this day
was a really good day for me and I was
playing very well in the first game.
I made it all the way until
I was the fourth guy left.
So I got fourth place and then in the
second game I was the fifth guy last left,
little bit worse, but
still fifth place, not bad.
In the third game I was the third guy
left some third place that was the best
I'd ever done.
And then I got knocked out.
But that got me close. I could almost,
I could almost taste that victory.
I really want it to win.
And then in the fourth game,
in the fourth game, Whoa,
something happened and it was kind of
confusing, but I'll try and explain it.
So I saw the best player from the other
team charging to the line with a ball in
his hand and he was going to throw his
ball at one of the best players from my
side who was also running to
throw the ball at the other guy.
They were both focused on each other.
Okay.
So they didn't see me and while they
were looking at each other and they were
charging towards the line to throw
the ball, they're balls at each other.
I came running in from the side and as
the other guy on the other side through
the ball at our best player, I threw
the ball at that guy and I nailed him.
I nailed it
and it felt good because if I could
get that good player on the game,
there's a better chance I could win.
But he was a really competitive
player and when I hit him,
he screamed really loud because he was
mad that he got hit and when he screamed,
everyone in the whole,
Jim looked at him.
Every one except little Billy.
Yeah,
little Billy.
That quiet kid that I talked about,
little Billy pulled a very sneaky move.
You see,
while I was distracted and focused on
throwing my balk at that other kid,
Billy snuck in out of nowhere and hit me,
hit me right in the side.
But here's the thing,
because everyone was looking
at the kid that's screamed.
No one saw me get hit.
Yeah,
no one saw it. Well, no one.
But Billy and I looked around and
I saw that no one was looking.
Everyone was looking at someone else
and then I just acted like it didn't
happen. I acted like I didn't get hit.
No one really noticed. Like
I said, it's except Billy.
Yeah.
And Billy just stood there looking at me
and he actually pointed at me and I could
see he wanted to say something like,
Hey,
you're out or I just hit you.
Okay.
But he didn't say anything.
And I felt bad for a quick moment.
But you know what?
I really wanted to win.
And a few seconds later there were balls
flying around again and Billy had to
move and the game went on and kids kept
throwing balls and kids kept getting
knocked out one by one, one
after the other, including Billy.
And when Billy walked off the court,
he did it very slowly just looking at me.
And then other kids got
knocked out and I kept going.
Yeah.
And then suddenly it was just me
and one other kid on the other side.
It was down to the two of us to
see who would be the champion.
And we both rushed to
the line ready to throw.
And then I did something very smart
instead of focused on focusing
on hitting him with my ball.
When he threw his ball at me, I just
dropped my ball. I just dropped it.
Okay.
And I focused on catching the
ball he had thrown, and I did it.
I caught that ball that he had thrown,
and that was it.
I had one,
I was the champion,
and I felt awesome.
I raised my hands into the air and I
celebrated by victory at a bunch of kids,
came back onto the court
and they congratulated me
for being the champ and gave
me high fives.
Okay.
And then,
okay.